>> IN CASE YOU HAVE NOT NOTICED,
IT'S VERY COLD OUTSIDE IN MOST
OF AMERICA.
HOW COLD?
SO COLD THAT SHARKS ARE FREEZING
TO DEATH IN CAPE GOD.
CITIES ARE SCRAPPING NEW YEAR'S
EVE PLANS.
BUT NOT THIS ONE.
JESSE WATERS STILL HAS TO COME
TO WORK.
IT COULD BE THE COLDEST NEW
YEAR'S EVE ON RECORD THAT THE
PRESIDENT TWEETS:
BUNDLE UP!
THANK YOU.
A DIRE WARNING 7 YEARS AGO THAT
THE ENTIRE POLAR ICE CAP MIGHT
DISAPPEAR BY 2014.
>> SCIENTISTS UNPRECEDENTED THAT
ONE STUDY ESTIMATED THAT IT
COULD BE COMPLETELY GONE DURING
SUMMER IN LESS THAN 22 YEARS.
ANOTHER NEW STUDY TO BE
PRESENTED BY THE U.S. NAVY
RESEARCHERS LATER THIS WEEK
WARNS IT COULD HAPPEN IN AS
LITTLE AS 7 YEARS.
7 YEARS FROM NOW.
>> ALL OF THOSE PEOPLE WERE
SITTING THERE SHIVERING IN FEAR
WONDERING WHEN GORE WOULD STOP
TALKING.
IN 10 YEARS THE WORLD WOULD
REACH A POINT OF NO RETURN.
WE REACHED THAT POINT OF NO
RETURN.
THE PRESIDENT DOESN'T LIKE
HAPPEN IF WE ARE FREEZING TO
DEATH.
IS HE RIGHT?
>> NO, HOT GETS HOTTER AND COLD
GETS COLDER.
HE DOESN'T UNDERSTAND THE
CLIMATE.
>> DID AL GORE UNDERSTAND IT?
>> GLOBAL WARM IS REAL AND
HUMANS ARE THE CAUSE.
>> I AGREE THAT THE CLIMATE IS
CHANGING.
WEIRD STUFF IS GOING ON.
WE CAN'T NECESSARILY CONTROL IT.
NOT EMOTIONALLY.
THAT'S BEEN VERY PROBLEMATIC.
>> IT'S LIKE A RELIGION.
YOU SHOULD BE THROWN IN PRISON.
HOW MUCH OF OUR ECONOMY DO WE
JOB CREATOR.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING]
>> BEING SUBSIDIZED BY THE
GOVERNMENT.
>> NO, IT'S NOT.
>> GO TO TEXAS.
>> I HAVE BEEN.
THEY ARE INVESTING IN SOLAR AND
WIND AT HISTORIC RATES AND THEIR
ENERGY COSTS ARE GOING DOWN.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING]
KNOW.
WATER BECAUSE OF GREENLAND'S ICE
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION?
>> WAS PRESIDENT TRUMP WRONG TO
TWEET THAT OUT?
>> NO.
HE IS TROLLING.
BUT THAT'S WHAT HE DOES.
EVERYONE IS LOSING THEIR MIND.
THE EXPLAINERS ARE SAYING IT'S
THAT CARBON EMISSIONS, THE ONE
OLUTION ON THE LEFT CAP IT AND
HURT OUR ECONOMY.
>> THAT'S NOT THE ONE SOLUTION.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING]
>> THIS IS A REAL PROBLEM.
>> I AM TIRED OF CELEBRITIES
TO THE U.N. TO TELL US HOW TO DO
LESS FOR THE PLAN EDIT.
-- PLANET.
POLLUTION AND CLIMATE CHANGE.
CHINA AND INDIA SHOULD BE DOING
>> I ACCEPT THE PREMISE THAT THE
CLIMATE IS CHANGE.
IN ARIZONA IT USED TO BE UNDER
THE OCEAN.
YOU CAN SEE SEA SHELLS.
I WILL GET A LECTURE ABOUT THE
WEATHER AND CLIMATE CHANGE.
AROUND A WILLIE NELS BUS.
>> OR PARTRIDGE FAMILY BUS.
>> OR FLINTSTONE'S BUS.